danke sehr guten Abend meine Damen und Herren ich
begrüße Sie ganz herzlich hier zu kaberett und
Kleinkunst im Zelt auf dem Mainzer lärchenberg und
ich darf ih wirklich ich freue mich sehr dass ich
wunderbare Gäste begrüßen darf denn politisch
kann man im Omer so gut wie gar nichts mehr
begrüßen oder ich meine am ersten vielleicht
das wunderbare vorausschauende und Weise
uchteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes zum Einsatz
der Bundeswehr im Innern da haben ja erstmal viele
irritiert reagiert die üblich Verdächtigen haben
gemeckert das sind ja die die immer schon wollten
dass die Soldaten aus Afghanistan und anderen
gefährlichen Orten zurückkommen ich meine da
muss man sie auch mal entscheiden die Soldaten
sollen nicht im Ausland kämpfen die sollen nicht
im Inland kämpfen ja was denn n sollen die alle
zusammen Däumchen drehen und mit dem dadurch
produzierten Wind die Energiewende unterstützen
oder was was mein sie wie frustrierend das ist
wenn sie Tag für Tag trainieren und selbst unter
den größten Optimisten in der tollen Truppe ist
die Hoffnung darauf dass der Russe noch mal
kommt auf den Nullpunkt gesunken jetzt haben
schon völlig frustrierte Uniformträger v schlagen
dass die Kameraden alle zusammen so lange in die
oder pinkeln sollen bis sie unter dem Jubel
der Bevölkerung wieder Sandsäcke schleppen
dürfen aber jetzt mal jetzt mal im Ernst
wir geben 31 Milliarden Euro jedes Jahr
dafür aus dass 196.000 aktive Soldaten da in
Kasernen rumlümmeln die zum Teil nur deshalb
noch nicht aufgelöst worden sind weil die
jeweiligen Bürgermeister vor Ort Angst haben
dass ohne diese Kasernen dem Ort entscheidende
Kaufkraft verloren gehen wird und jetzt habe
ich auch begriffen warum wir maximal 7 bis
9000 Soldaten eigentlich dauerhaft nur im
aus im Einsatz haben können der Rest wird
an der Heimatfront dringend gebraucht die
kämpfen an Wurst und kästheken an trinkbütchen
und in eckknäpen für den Erhalt der heimischen
Infrastruktur der Mensch auch der Mensch in
Uniform braucht eine Aufgabe und dem Steuerzahler
ist es inzwischen ja längst egal aus welchem
Fenster seine Gelder geschmissen werden der
Steuerzahler ist schon froh wenn das Fenster vor
aufgemacht wird damit er no den Glaser bezahlen
muss und sehen Sie in diesem trostlosen
Alltag der ebenso unterbezahlten wie
überflüssigen vaterlandsverteidiger hat jetzt
das Bundesverfassung Gericht mit seinem Urteil
ein kleines Licht der Hoffnung angezündet in
Zukunft darf die Truppe in ganz bescheidenem
Umfang auch im Innen eingesetzt werden
z.B wenn jetzt Terroristen ein Flugzeug
entführen und damit drohen damit sag wir mal
das Bundeskanzleramt oder den Bundestag zu
zerstören dann darf die Bundeswehr in
Zukunft das Flugzeug immer noch nicht
abschießen aber Sie dürfen es in Zukunft
zur Landung zwingen z.B im Bundestag oder im
Kanzler und damit die fußtruppe nicht
völlig verzweifelt hat man noch da
ein ganz kleines Fenster aufgemacht und
zwar das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt
die Bundeswehr darf im Innern eingesetzt
werden wenn ein unmittelbar bevorstehender
Schadenseintritt von katastrophischen
Dimensionen droht da weiß man auch
endlich mal wozu man oberste Richter hat ein
unmittelbar bevorstehender Schadenseintritt
von katastrophischen Dimension ahen
sie wie lange ich an diesen Text
ich frage mich bis heute seit
wann die Drogen die man braucht
um sowas zu formulieren legalisiert sind meine
dam